and tom sherwood political reporter for
wrc tv in washington dc
they join us to discuss their recent
book dream city race power and the
decline of washington d.c
harry asked jaffe why did you call your
new book dream city
a number of reasons i think that people
often come to washington dc with some
kind of a dream in mind
you know school kids come here from
cherry oaks ohio or wherever and they
might dream of becoming president one
day uh congress people come here with an
idea about how they'd like to change the
world
and uh
our principal characters were largely
civil rights activists who came to
washington dc after the civil rights
movement down south had come to a close
with the dream of making washington d.c
the first
city run by african americans
by government
and making it a place that was
noteworthy and made the dream of
empowerment that was begun down in the
south true
who's your favorite character in the
book
well i won't lie
marion barry is his favorite character
he's obviously the principal character
apart from the city itself
he's just an extraordinary person he has
made so much news nationally
internationally
usually for the wrong things
unfortunately
but he's a complex person we've found in
researching his life
he's growing up in a
family of mother and foreign sisters
his
getting involved into the civil rights
movement at the same time he's also
studying to have a chemistry degree
at fisk university
there are all kinds of things about
marion barry that don't come through the
national international news that he was
the mayor caught smoking crack cocaine
other than marion barry who's another
person that you wrote about that is
memorable
well i would i would go for al arrington
who is the uh in a sense the hero of the
book uh he uh like marion barry uh
the the son of a sharecropper uh worked
uh the fields pulling tobacco in north
carolina
came to washington dc uh as part of a
migration of of african americans who
came from the south to washington to
seek their fortunes
only uh where where marion barry took a
political path uh
which took him to uh to places where he
maybe didn't plan to go al arrington
became a police officer
uh developed a stable relationship with
his wife worked his way up through the
the ranks of the police department and
wound up
being the african-american metropolitan
police department sergeant who
investigated marion barry and was a
crucial i would say
a key element in his in the
investigation that actually led to the
vista
set up and
arrested marion barry i think it's
important though al arrington was
the officer who had his hand on the
doorknob
as they were prepared to burst into the
vista hotel room to arrest marion barry
and the conflicts and and harrington's
mind as a black person
uh
going into arrest yet another black
person
it's a high profile sense of that case
the feelings he had there would make for
some of the dramatic moments exactly we
asked
al arrington how he felt
when he when he reached marion barry he
was the first
police officer to reach marion barry and
i said how did it feel he said it was
like a knife in the heart
because while he'd been hunting this man
for a full year
when he got him
he realized that this is this is my
brother
uh and and he had terrible conflict that
i think a lot of african americans feel
in general about you know their own
brothers how they deal with a white
society and that those are some of the
things that we try to bring out in dream
city what do you do for a living
full-time
i'm a political reporter for wrc tv
channel 4 here in washington the
nbc owned station here in the district
and
that's what i do full time too much time
how long have you done that i've been
doing it since 1989 i used to work for
the washington post covering local
politics marion barry and
chuck robb in virginia
but in 1989 the tv station barry was
still then the mayor and the station
wanted someone they thought could report
on the city and report specifically on
marion barry
so they waived some additional dollars
in my face and said come try tv tom stop
being that newspaper journalist and i
did it it's been fun for five years what
year did you come to washington i've
moved here in 1974
i worked for john w davis a member of
congress
who was defeated that year
by larry mcdonald and so i needed the
job and i got a job at the washington
post as a desk editor in 1974. where's
homer isn't it atlanta georgia
i must say that i was in washington in
1968 and 69 as a navy reservist at the
washington navy yard which was my first
real introduction to the local
washington
but i'm from atlanta larry mcdonald was
the congressman went down on
k-a-l-double the john birch society
member from north from the
congressional district right outside of
atlanta what was john davis politics a
former judge 12 moderate north georgia
congressman 12 years had a drinking
problem
and
it got increasingly distant from his
district and
came got a loof in washington and got
defeated harry jaffe what do you do
full-time i am a national editor at
washingtonian magazine and i
write about uh local politics local
business uh
whatever comes up uh
columns longer articles where you from
originally philadelphia
where'd you go to school
i went to school of public schools in
philadelphia and then i went to college
dickinson college in pennsylvania and
when did you first come to washington
uh well like tom i came to work for
somebody on capitol hill i came in 1978
to work for patrick leahy as his press
secretary however i was here in 1971 uh
to protest the vietnam war where i was
first arrested at dupont circle
first arrested
more than once we make some news here
do you both live in the district yes
i live in the district with my wife and
three children i have two daughters who
are in the public school
public elementary school
so
yeah i think that for tom and i
having a stake in the district of
columbia was part of our motivation for
writing this book i think that
while the book is you know may seem
critical there's a tremendous amount of
affection that tom and i share for the
for the city
will marion barry be the next mayor of
washington d.c
barring an extraordinary event which i
can't scope out in my mind
marion barry should beat republican
carol schwartz in november and a couple
of lesser-known independent candidates
who will also be on the ballot but his
primary win with 47 percent of the vote
was extraordinary
many people expected him to have a very
good chance of winning but no one only
one person out of the entire city
predicted barry would get that high of a
vote
how did he do it
well he
did it
i think two two ways in particular he he
exploited what is a a
tremendous amount of anger and defiance
uh across the board in the black
community that we
write about and try to explain and get
to the roots of in dream city
secondly uh his uh
plea as a uh on religious grounds that
he
uh was a redeemed individual that he had
seen the bottom and worked his way back
up has a a tremendous appeal
to african americans and thirdly and i
think most importantly
marion barry is a a masterful politician
he knows how to get people to the polls
to vote for him uh and the mechanics of
that which is something that as we point
out in dream city he learned
in snek the student non-violent
coordinating committee
in the deep south during the civil
rights movement he has brought all of
those tactics and all those talents to
bear in in every one of his campaigns so
he brought people to the polls
and he brought people to the polls who
hadn't voted before which is one of the
things that i think
he deserves quite a lot of credit for he
registered as many as 12 000 new voters
or had some role in registering that
many new voters he also appealed to the
middle class black washingtonians who
know that the city government is uh
wasting too much money it's going to
have to be cut either by the city
officials or by congress
and so in looking to someone to cut the
city budget
we're talking in the middle class black
community we're often talking about
their jobs and their contracts with city
government
who would you best trust to cut the
government someone who has denounced the
government or someone who perhaps built
it and knows it best and knows that
while he must make cuts will make cuts
that will do while doing his best to
protect them and their jobs those are
practical politics
tip o'neill once said you know all
politics is local and the fact is that's
true here in washington for all the
people who only know marion barry
through the nasty headlines and the
videotape of the crack cocaine
don't know the extraordinary work he did
in this in washington to open up the
doors of government to the black people
of washington who were shut out for
years decades
and people remember that
give us a profile of washington d.c how
many people live here what's the racial
makeup of the community and where's the
power and how much does it cost to make
this city work
well let me begin by saying that we've
got uh fewer than 600 000 uh residents
which is a plummeting
number of inhabitants uh at its height
the city had 800 000 people and that was
i think in the 50s so there's been a
steady drain of of people
uh the city is is divided i think by two
waterways primarily
the anacostia river which is a tributary
of the potomac uh separates the the
poorer
uh black population
from the rest of the city and there's
often a uh a saying of across the tracks
uh or across the river across the tracks
in southern town in washington dc across
the rivers across the anacostia
then there is the rock creek
rock creek itself and rock creek park
the wealthier white
population lives west of the park
and
in the in the center of the city and in
in neighborhoods all across that the
great area between the park and
anacostia river is a thriving black
middle class
fine churches good schools
people that just want their piece of the
american dream they just want to live
well send their kids to college and
follow the uh the pathway that a lot of
black middle class people have followed
in this city where's the money come from
to operate the community and how much
local power do they have
well
a lot of the money comes from the very
people who live here and work here
it's commonly believed that the city is
simply awarded the federal government
that's not true
the budget's 3.7 billion dollars a year
3.7 billion
most of that money
is raised through local businesses and
local taxpayers individuals like harry
and i
that's where the money comes from we
have a thriving business community here
the downtown washington was rebuilt in
the 1980s
they pay a great deal on taxes many
people think they don't pay enough taxes
but that's where the money comes from
and the power unfortunately
belongs to congress under the
constitution the current the congress
has full authority over the district of
columbia and only since 1974 has there
been any kind of local home rule
government with an elected mayor and
city council to run the day-to-day
affairs of the city
but everything is subject to disapproval
by the congress
it doesn't matter whether you're for
against abortion congress and the
president have stopped abortions in this
city and if they don't like the color of
taxi cabs they can also change that so
everything life and death matters
congress controls
second to that is the essentially white
business community that uh much of which
is located outside of the city now
also controls a great deal of the
economic wealth of the city although
there are substantially wealthy people
black people in washington the power
generally resides in congress the white
business community and then the people
who have limited powers to affect their
local government who's jeff cohen
jeff cohen is a uh local washingtonian
uh who uh
born and raised here went to school here
uh befriended marion barry early on
uh saw marion barry as a politician who
he could relate to
and became
a uh
i guess godfather to marion barry's
son
vacation with marion barry in nantucket
and
use those contacts for his own
self-aggrandizement he's a developer
who
would use the city government as kind of
a banker of last resort to guarantee
loans that uh
made him wealthy
uh
at the end of the barrie first barry
regime uh jeff cohen went bankrupt and
that's in no small part because he lost
his patron marion barry
shows a a fundamental conflict
where a businessman will
take advantage of his uh his dealings
with the city government
you say that uh when he filed for
bankruptcy he had liabilities of 54
million dollars and assets of 112 000
but yet right after filing bankruptcy
was found to still have his home and
this sid will friend schools and going
to the white house or someplace with
bill clinton can you explain that
well i would say that uh that bankruptcy
in in this country is a is a way to give
people a second chance
he
he
did have to uh to pay off some of his
loans but his father is a wealthy man
and i think that he used those kinds of
ties to
continue living pretty much the
lifestyle that he uh he was living when
he was uh when he was on the on the high
and it's true that the rich go through
bankruptcy far different than people of
modest or more normal means there are
ways
with lawyers and others to get to have
bankruptcy but still take vacations to
alaska
but i think the relationship with
jeffrey cohen uh with marion barry
demonstrates another aspect we try to
point out in dream city is that for all
the rhetoric about ant uh white business
establishment not hiring black people
that marian barry which is and was and
is quite comfortable in the suites of
washington talking to the powers the
white power structure
one of his
stated goals in this campaign and others
on the positive side it's been that he
is a person who's able to talk to the
poorest of the poor and the richest of
the rich uh a cynic might turn that
around and say that he that he scams the
poor and cuddles the rich
certainly there are problems in the city
in terms of not new taxes but collecting
simply the taxes that are owed from this
major business community and some people
believe that barry has been so close to
that community that the boards and
commissions that should be collecting
those taxes don't because of barry's
influence with them who's ivanhoe
donaldson
ivanhoe donaldson a a true
uh star and leading light of the student
nonviolent coordinating committee uh one
of the most brilliant political
strategists to come out of the southern
civil rights movement son of a
a new york police officer
came to washington
shortly after mary and barry did
and became marion barry's
alter ego his principal political
advisor
engineered his first political victories
in both in city council and his first
mayoral victory uh unfortunately for
various
reasons some of which we try to reach
into some of which are hard to divine
uh ivanhoe donaldson
got into debt
uh when he was a head of the deploy the
department of employment security
one of the top
jobs in the barrie administration and he
began to embezzle money
he was caught
and he admitted to
embezzling 190 thousand dollars from the
city government and served time in jail
for that and it was a tremendous blow to
to barry because it happened in 86 when
barry was starting to slide
down
uh the path that would lead him to to
personal dissipation
losing ivanhoe donaldson as a rudder at
that point was was crucial you asked who
was my favorite character well ivanhoe
is the saddest character for all the
reasons harry just stated
he worked for the department of
employment services the job for that
agency of course is to get jobs for the
people in the city unemployment in the
african-american community hovers from
males is around close to 50 on a regular
basis
the concept that a a fixture of the
civil rights movement like ivanhoe had
been corrupted and in the process of
trying to govern uh was just really sad
in many ways ivanhoe took money and and
sponsored parties for orphans and did
all kinds of good things but he also
started driving mercedes and owning an
expensive condominium and
buying credit card bills for dinner at
washington's expensive restaurants so he
lost his bearings much like marion barry
did
ivanhoe went to jail for three years and
he's been back in town working as a
consultant trying to help marion barry
and others and so he's also a tragic
figure in this uh in dream city right
now i hope that we can write maybe a
future chapter that he's turned himself
around who's married treadwell
mary treadwell
uh strong woman brilliant woman uh
marion barry second wife
uh why has he had this he's on his
fourth marriage right now
he was briefly married when he was in
school down in tennessee
and mary treadwell
his second marriage
crucial in the early
years of marion barry's political life
here in washington
in developing pride inc which was a a
self-help
uh political
job
bank
that operated back in the in the late
60s
and again a sad story to be told here uh
as ivanhoe did uh
mary became a little bit uh more
involved in the in the trappings of the
of the uh organization she was running
wound up driving a jaguar and living in
the watergate hotel
and she was also found herself on the
wrong end of a of a of a lawsuit was was
charged with embezzling money i don't
think she was ever correct me if i'm
wrong she was not ever
found guilty of that it was a lesser
charge and just for this very moment i
can't remember but it's much lesser
charge than what she had been been
accused of but she is another another
fallen figure who had to serve time you
uh you though have some scenes that you
describe in the book and language uh in
quote marks
of uh when marion barry was out
allegedly philandering with other women
but came home one night and you have
mary treadwell putting a gun to his head
on the pillow as he hit as his head hit
the pillow and and suggesting the rather
strong language he shouldn't be doing
that anymore that she would like to take
care of the situation yes we do have
that language in the book it's uh
well we we've got that from
information from um
contemporaneous uh people who are aware
of what happened who she spoke to and we
also uh told her we were reporting it
and did did you speak to her about the
book interview before we told yes we
interviewed harry interviewed her
extensively but i also went to her and
told her what we were publishing
uh how did you divide your
responsibilities in the book
whoever had the time i'll answer that
because harry uh harry's name is on the
book first and that's an appropriate
place because he was the driving force
he is the person who called after the
arrest of marion barry in 1990 and we
didn't really know each other except
being in the same city
and said you know this city and this man
is a hell of a book and let's do it and
uh but as a magazine writer more focused
on long-term projects uh harry was in a
position to
spearhead the research and gather we
worked in his attic and as a television
reporter more attuned to the day-to-day
types of things that are going on it was
a combination that we did i had a lot of
research from my years of a decade of
covering mary and barry in the city a
lot of files left over for my days at
the washington post so all that went
into dream city but harry was a driving
force to get the book done
and we decided he would uh write in his
voice and that would be the editor of it
so we wouldn't be writing two different
books and then trying to smash them
together like books often do
i think people say about dream city that
it reads very well whatever the
criticisms are it reads very well i
think that's because we chose to let
harry write the book uh with my input
is that right harry well you you were
you were so kind to me tom that i uh
i when my agent came to me and said
this is a this is a book that will do
well and i can find someone to uh a
publisher in this case simon schuster uh
to uh to go ahead and publish the book
i frankly didn't think i had uh enough
reporting experience and didn't know the
characters and didn't know the story as
well as
uh the
tom sherwood who was then and still is
the the principal dean of washington
reporters when it comes to uh to local
politics i mean tom's a guy who
knows mary and barry uh i i think they
have a relationship if i'm not mistaken
that kind of goes beyond hey i'm a
reporter and he's a politician there's
an understanding there that i i i never
could attain so i i uh
worked well with tom
as a as the as for providing me with the
kind of material and grist and detail
that i needed would marion barry talk to
you for the book
no he didn't talk officially for the
book of course he had talked for a
decade so
i told him he said no he we wrote him
letters and i said please talk to us and
he wouldn't talk to us and he said
what's in it for me and i said well the
fact is we know all the bad stuff i want
to talk to you about the good stuff well
it turned out we didn't know all the bad
stuff that surprised us but uh he didn't
want to do it
and even now he doesn't really like to
talk about the book he doesn't dispute
the book he doesn't he just says that
we're i'm a better reporter than i am a
writer i don't know what that means it's
just a way he just kind of dismisses it
he says look the book happened all these
things happened in the past i'm the new
person i'm a new marion barry i i
acknowledge my problems with women with
drugs uh with my kids taking my hand off
the torah
for the government and i'm moving on and
so he doesn't want to address the book
in that reason but i wish he had talked
to us it would have been a better book
who else did not talk to you or would
not agree to talk to you well
surprisingly enough uh very few people
uh
talk to you if he would not
uh rufus cathedral who was she by the
way who is she effie barry uh marion
barry's third wife who he married just
before running for a mayor in 1978
and who's you know fathered i'm sorry
uh mothered his first his only child
christopher
who stuck with him all during his
travails uh and during his very public
uh demise in in court came to court
every single day
uh and sat there and had to uh you know
pain stricken
listen to the testimony of marion
barry's various paramours
uh i sat behind effie barry for many of
those court dates
she decided not to speak to us
and uh and i think i you know i try to
think why she didn't i think that she
also wanted to leave uh the the episode
behind her and left town shortly after
after so
we tried to find out more about her with
me there's some biographical material in
there about her uh but she's moved to to
hampton virginia where she's been
teaching at the hampton university there
uh she had planned to write her own
books she talked about writing her own
book uh she was portrayed pretty much as
the long-suffering wife under marion
barry although friends said that
she too had her own active lifestyle and
they lived apart she once even admitted
that maybe in all the times that they
had been married from 1978 until 1991 or
whatever it was that they maybe had had
dinner six times together
because they led separate lives
it was an arrangement which one friend
of effie barry said she was strong
enough to stay but too weak to leave
was karen
johnson let's see karen johnson
uh
one of the earliest uh uh
lovers of marion barry to kind of make
it into the public spotlight because
there was a an allegation
that she supplied married barry with uh
with cocaine
and she in the early 1980s yeah this
this is this is uh if marion barry's
first term began in 1979
uh two years later he began his
relationship with with karen johnson uh
she served time in jail
uh and uh
that episode was i think the first crack
in in marion barry's public facade that
linked him
with uh another woman
and uh and drugs
how did he meet her
in the nightclub here in town
as mayor
he was mayor um
marion barry um
had a notorious reputation as a
womanizer uh do you hate that word just
it's a terrible word
and but he was even when he was on the
school board
people who worked there at the time said
you know as a school board president he
would walk out into the to the audience
and and ask people if they're single or
not and where do they live and what's
your phone number and then get a
business number then say no i mean your
home number i mean he was just unabashed
about it
karen johnson again only because of the
drug connection with her her boyfriend
who alleged was alleged to have provided
the cocaine for marion barry did that
become public at all how did his
relationship with her work you've got
quite a bit in there how you know he
would go to her oh at night he was a
nocturnal visit i mean he was barry
called himself a night out after a lot
of publicity about his activities but
barry simply would would have his
limousine drive him to her apartment it
was just as we found out one of many
apartments he visited over time with
various women around in the end what did
she did she testify against him
no she never did and there was a jail
there she went to jail and there were
allegations and some quite explicit uh
information that uh
pinned uh payments
to karen johnson
by marion barry's uh
friends to business friends business
friends
people who actually delivered cash to
her in order to buy her silence and uh
for whatever reason it did buy her
silence you name those friends yes we do
who are they
uh
see john clyburn and roy
john and where do you get those kind of
names well they acknowledged giving
money to her they said it wasn't they
acknowledged giving the money to karen
johnson but they didn't say they said it
wasn't for any payoff and no one could
prove there were payoffs uh karen
johnson would refuse to uh to testify
she went to jail i've forgotten how many
months she stayed in jail she had a
small son the prosecutors thought that
if they sent her to jail perhaps being
separated from her son would make her
testify she chose not to and to this day
she has never told her side of the story
she's had some conversations
but
with one tv interview but she's really
never told the whole story and of course
marion barry hasn't either who's charles
lewis
charles lewis
uh
a son of a a very wealthy virgin islands
family
who
had difficulty
with drugs of his own
before he met marion barry came to
washington d.c
worked in the city government met marion
barry in the mid 1980s
and uh then when when barry started to
kind of go downhill he would often go to
the islands
for entertainment
and uh
one of the first times that he went down
to the virgin islands with rasheeda
moore
who was the uh the paramour who actually
led to his downfall uh it was with
charles lewis uh on a boat
uh where they uh
is according to testimony by both of
those folks uh there was a quite a bit
of drugs and marijuana and cocaine
consumed on the boat in the virgin
islands with charles lewis and uh and
rashida moore present at the time
charles lewis became a principal uh
accuser of marion barry in court
testimony i think it's important to know
that charles lewis had been here in the
70s then went back to the islands but
then was currying something we don't we
cannot say it was drugs but i had a lot
of
murky jobs let's just call it that but
he was a catalyst that really started
the specific downfall of marion barry
because in in 1988 in december of 1988
that's when marion barry went to the
ramada inn here in washington downtown
to visit
chuck lewis
as it turned out it was in fact to get
drugs at the time
barry said it was just somebody he knew
and that chuck lewis was down and out
needed the job and
tried to give all these various
explanations but it was clear at that
time that something was up and that
prompted the prosecutor jay stevens uh
to pretty much reopen an investigation
into marion barry's activities and they
pursued both chuck lewis uh and barry at
the same time when was the decision made
by jay stevens the former u.s attorney
in the district to pursue mary what was
the date well interestingly enough
just going back a little bit joe
digenova who preceded jay stevens had a
number of investigations
uh
that
were terminated by jay stevens when jay
stephens got into office he said you
haven't gotten the guy
why don't you just drop everything i
think it was important to note jay
stevens is a white conservative
republican former white house
aide who was appointed by
reagan
by reagan right
and
when the ramada inn
uh
episode
uh came about which means that when it
became clear that mary and barry had
visited chuck lewis and that there was
cocaine in the room and chuck lewis had
apparently tried to
give some cocaine to one of the
chambermaids at the ramada inn when that
happened there were police officers
involved uh there was enough going on
that
and al arrington became involved he's
the mpd
police sergeant who got involved there
was enough at that point and that would
have been december 1988
right well
it was late december so the decision
actually to do a full-scale
investigation came only after the d.c
police department which largely had been
under the thumb of marion barry
ike fullwood and then chief
turner
refused to try to cover up the sense
that it was just too messy and the
police chiefs the police chief and his
principal assistant forward
pretty much washed their hands and said
we're not getting involved in this and
as the the within the coming weeks
january of 89 is really when the
decision was made to do a full
investigation of this grand jury
investigation how many times has marian
barry been elected mayor of the city of
washington
so far
three times i'd say three and a half
because
he's so close to being elected the
fourth time which is an interesting
point that few americans really quite
understand is that is that how young the
local political system is here uh marion
barry when he was elected uh his first
three times was only the second mayor
uh to be elected lok you know by the by
the citizenry of washington dc since the
1800s who was the first
walter washington in 1974.
when congress passed home rule for the
city in 1973
and
walter washington who had been a first
the appointed mayor by lyndon johnson in
the 60s
ran and won the first term
as an elected mayor and then ran again
in 1978
but lost out to barry in a three-way
race that's remarkably similar in many
respects to the race we just had
but now walter washington is retired so
then the city has had in effect
as mayors walter washington
marion barry
sharon pratt kelly and if marion barry
is elected again uh in 20 years it will
have had three mayors and marion barry
for most of that time what happened to
sharon pratt
dixon kelly she was a well politically
she was a disaster she used to say that
she was um and she's still in office
until january 2nd 1995.
um she would say that i'm not a
politician like she came out of the she
was a hometown washingtonian who had
worked as a lawyer and was worked for
the prep for the power company
and she ran on the reform platform in
1990 as sharon pride dickson saying that
she would fix all the problems that
marion barry had created that she was
embarrassed for home her hometown that
she was not a politician but she was a
politician she just turned out to be a
bad one on so many different levels she
had been the national treasure of the
democratic national committee she had
been a member of the democratic national
committee as a national committee woman
from washington since 1977.
in 1982 she had run the mayoral campaign
of patricia roberts harris another
hometown washingtonian with a national
reputation who failed to unseat barry so
kelly mayor dixon was in fact involved
in the city but she turned she had a
tremendous victory upset victory in 1990
against some city council candidates and
and the world lay at her feet
but rather than embracing the various
elements that opposed her she fought
with him and she ended up fighting with
the congress the courts the media
the city council
and the business community
it was either her way of the highway in
so many cases that people said forget it
we can't work with you and while she did
some things as a reform mayor
her personality and her politics
isolated her to the extent that she was
that even the washington post which had
endorsed her in 1990 didn't do it this
time population is 580 000 something
like that right how many what percentage
are african americans seventy percent
just under seventy percent there's about
i'd say two or three percent uh hispanic
and asian
over a person a day is killed you you
say at some point in your book that a
young black man is killed once a day
why
well
primarily the drug trade
primarily the lack of of opportunity the
lack of perceived opportunity
you know one of the one of the events
that we describe
is uh when uh
george bush
who was uh starting at another war on
drugs
uh wanted an example to go on national
tv and talk about and so he arranged for
the dea
to set up drug enforcement the drug
enforcement set up a drug buy in
lafayette
square which is right across from the
white house and indeed it happened
the
african-american from washington d.c who
was set up had to be given directions to
the white house he lived in a
neighborhood
maybe as the crow flies a mile or two
away didn't know how to get there there
so there's a part of washington that is
so enclosed and divorced from the rest
of the city that the drug culture the
drug life uh and the lack of of uh of
respect for human for for life can
become that vicious where are the
murders committed
uh most of the murders are cut are
committed in southeast and in parts of
northeast washington rarely in this city
unlike miami and other tourist towns
tourism peanuts number two industry here
do we have reports of tourists being
attacked and shot i think one tourist in
10 years maybe has been shot and killed
that was one person
an elderly gentleman who had strayed
away from downtown and any regular parts
that tourists might go to you know we
have a terrible problem with guns in the
city we have the strongest anti-gun law
in america here no one can own a handgun
if you didn't have it before 1977
but the borders are poorest of virginia
and maryland a lot of the guns in fact
come from virginia uh another thing
this city does not have the established
territorial gangs that some urban areas
have and so there are a lot of fights in
the drug community over who's going to
control what what
drug trafficking there is in some of the
poorer neighborhoods and those are
constantly people being killed where do
the whites live in the community
almost entirely west of rock creek park
in the northwest quadrant of the city
and i'd say probably ninety percent of
the white population lives in that
particular area ward three some in ward
two which is georgetown
on capitol hill how many murders
committed in ward three i'd say maybe
one or two
that's about it sometimes none in a full
year
yeah two or three at most and there have
been sensational crimes
an armored guard uh security guard being
shot at a restaurant that type of thing
what's so attractive
about
crack
cocaine it's cheap makes you feel
let me tell you this quarter what people
say it's cheap makes you feel great and
and it's highly addictive that if you uh
that you if you first try it one or two
times
that i'm told to hire such that you just
cannot believe that uh
you can do anything else but get that
high again that mother's been known
obviously to
leave their children and
infant children and go out in search of
crack cocaine having sex uh in exchange
not for money but for crack cocaine it
is quite powerful how much is it
i think you can get it for five dollars
yeah i mean it's you can get it comes in
little tiny plastic uh containers you
can get it for as much as little as five
or ten dollars there's one thing about
the murder rate that i think is
important to to point out is that
you know my personal criticism of marion
barry is not so much his personal
failings but his failure as a mayor and
in his last six years especially
uh he allowed the public housing
projects to deteriorate to
to the point where washington dc's
public housing what became the worst in
the entire nation
which is a breeding ground for crime for
health problems for everything secondly
under his watch the the police
department was was very much crippled uh
because of lack of funds because of
cronyism because of uh
poor technology so the the marriage or
the convergence of those two aspects of
barry's
government
public housing into into deterioration
the police uh
not prepared to handle the influx of
crime is what contributed to the murder
rate how long did marion barry spend in
jail
six months
where did he go he briefly was at
petersburg virginia and then there was
an alleged incident there of sexual
misconduct with a female visitor what
does that mean
well it means that the
it was alleged by another inmate that
while marion barry was in the visiting
room with a female visitor that the
female visitor performed oral sex on him
but you say in the book
that the person that did the alleging
was a white inmate right that was yet
another one this dream city points out
again and again that nothing is seen
through just clear eyes of race and
racist racial fears and racism plays a
role in virtually everything and again
uh this was an allegation that the
inmate that was uh made these
allegations against barry uh was white
who had worked in the in the warden's
office and uh didn't like barry and that
and uh but it was enough was found that
the prison system the federal prison
system did in fact move barry to a place
in pennsylvania but i would say in
researching that very incident
that uh had a direct conversation with
the inmate who alleged the incident he
never specifically saw what he said he
saw it's just that
it looked like something was happening
he never specifically uh saw the actual
act
who's jim sleeper
jim sleeper
is a columnist for newsday right now uh
he wrote a book
called the closest of strangers
which is about uh the relationship
between liberal whites and blacks in new
york city let me read uh you know this
course it's on the back jacket it says
and he's writing about your book he says
a vivid account of how the complex
legacies of white racism
and white guilt
commingled
with the deep hurt and mistrust at the
center of black politics
to let one man mary and berry preempt
the development of an integrated civic
culture in our nation's capital what
does that mean
it's a mouthful
i'll read it again
maybe we could take it in part well i i
think that that he he makes a number of
good points that we try to develop in
dream city first of all there is the
tremendous mistrust and distrust of the
white establishment uh is at the root of
politics here
a congress is
you know in fact runs the city or has
the power to run the city this is a
white establishment organization by and
large
the second thing that i think is
important here is that politics in
washington dc are so young and so
fragile
and marion barry's expertise
as a political operator
allowed him to
commandeer
control
of the democratic party which uh
has ten to one advantage over the
republican party
uh to control the city council
which which was called the marionettes
during his uh his tenure as as mayor
um and to basically
foy you know kind of put down any
attempt to develop a political uh uh
counterpoint to his own control the fact
is the white racism he speaks of is that
there is the home rule for the city
limited home rule and it was reluctantly
given by congress in fact the congress
was
distracted by watergate and other
matters
but many black people rightly feel
and know that if white people could they
would take this city back and not allow
black people to run
that is heard uh not on public
television programs like this but you
can hear that remark as you go around
the country in the city
in fact i was in florida this this past
week and someone wrote in saying well
those people have elected marion barry
they should have the
home rule should be taken away and
congress should run the city again and i
think that's one of the things that
people don't quite understand the people
of washington the african-americans who
live here and many whites of goodwill
resent
very much the the external forces of the
country always talk about those people
in washington as if they're somehow
sub-human and i think race does play a
major factor there and that and so when
some african americans who voted for
marion barry this time uh said look
here's an in-your-face vote you think
you're we're you're worried about
marrying barry and he shouldn't be our
mayor we're sick of you telling us who
we're going to vote for i'm going to
vote for marion barry in addition i
think he'll do a good job i'm going to
vote just because you hate himself and
that's a racial insecurity that's not
the best reason to vote for mayor but
that's a legitimate reason and i can
understand that i get that feeling
throughout the city go back to rashida
moore and al arrington
did you interview rashina moore for this
book
uh we attempted to by the time that we
made that attempt she was in the witness
protection program
long gone from washington what does that
mean
uh it means that after she testified
against marion barry in uh in federal
court
she was essentially given
a a new identity a new home by the u.s
marshals and the fbi uh because she her
they considered her life to be in danger
if she stayed in washington dc
go back to the beginning of the
investigation you mentioned earlier
about jay stevens going after
marionberry after the ramada end
incident
how did they
find rashida more
the meaning the uh the fbi
rashida moore of course being the
beautiful model that barry had uh met
previously and carried on a relationship
with
that's part of the owl arrington story
is is the uh it's the unraveling of
connections uh uh charles lewis had a
had an address book
that had lots of names and i think there
was an rc in there or something uh
which was regina moore's nickname and
it was i don't go through all the steps
because it's quite complicated but we
laid out in the book in dream city how
they finally discovered that rashida
moore is the daughter of a local
washington woman who is the organist in
the local church
and they attempt to talk to her and
initially they're going to but then it
all falls apart
and they bring her in
through
classic interrogation techniques to talk
to her and she doesn't want to say
anything and then she um and she leaves
but then ultimately she's arrested on a
small charge out in los angeles i think
a driving charge or something like that
and they're able to persuade her to talk
now again what's the year
where this investigation starts it
starts in january of 89 rashida more was
not actually brought in to testify until
christmas
okay but you at some point point out in
your book that she was down and out and
on food stamps and welfare and she had
children and where were they they were
in los angeles
and there was a problem with her whether
the children were staying i think for a
while with the father of the children um
i don't want to misremember this on
national television so i'm going to be
careful about that but
they were i think was a driving charge
in which they arrested her and they said
they had found her they went out to talk
to her and al arrington the bible had an
impact in this and you keep bringing up
his relationship to
the bible and his use of it explain that
and again al arrington is a washington
dc police man yes uh
al had a a near fatal uh traffic
accident in the in the mid-80s and uh it
became a very religious experience for
him because they the uh
a minister was called to the hospital to
administer last rites the doctors
thought he was finished
he recovered and it became a religious
awakening for him
he
when he was interrogating
a number of the people who were close
friends of marion barry or who would and
who would you would expect to be
protecting marion barry he would read
passages of the bible
uh that appealed to them
essentially to a higher
god
than the political god that marion barry
had become
and uh it worked in enough cases and it
worked with uh with charles lewis
uh and he also would he would he had
this
technique of drawing fish
little fish had a big fish up here and
then we'd draw a little fish down here
and he would talk to various people and
he'd say now
you're down here you're one of these
little fish we're going out he would
draw a line towards the big fish he said
we're not worried about these little
fish we're going towards the big fish
and
anybody any of the fish are getting our
way you know we're gonna have to deal
with when you know something we want to
know what it is because we don't want
you we want the big fish so in addition
to the to the religious aspects we had
people in tears in the interrogation
rooms uh with his ability to call upon
the the deep religious uh
culture of an african-american community
in addition to that was the cold steel
of the cops saying here's what we're
doing and don't you forget it where is
al arrington today
al arrington lives in prince george's
county maryland he is a suburb of
washington dc he is selling real estate
he'd be happy for you to call him
he's actually part of the uh
the one of the problems in washington is
it's not the white people who are
fleeing the city but the black middle
class they have left in
tens of thousands since the late 80s and
they've moved in many respects to prince
george's county just over the uh the d.c
line in suburban maryland where there
are tremendous neighborhoods of homes
and schools and and in fact that county
now is 50 african-american
and the great fear for the city as a
city resident for me is that whoever is
mayor has got to do something to help
draw
people like them back to the city they
are the foundation for any city and now
they need to come back
you uh paint the picture of the
night that uh
i know our audience saw the vista hotel
incident where they arrested marionberry
you paint the picture leading up to that
where did you get that information uh we
got it largely from uh from uh our al
arrington uh we got it from some of the
uh the court records uh tom sherwood was
on hand uh he was the first reporter at
the vista
yeah i got there was an eerie silence
there was just nothing there was not
expected pandemonium and there was just
eerie silence and quiet the mayor's car
was there
the hotel people were just coming and
going as they normally do with a luxury
hotel downtown then suddenly these two
plain clothes officers come out and the
mayor's security guard is in custody and
so i walked up to him and said i called
him by his name and said what's going on
i'd heard that barry had been arrested
of course i'd played dumb like reporters
tried to do
and these two police officers looked
like they were about to arrest me so i
backed off and went inside the hotel and
within the next 20 minutes or so we
discovered that in fact the mayor of
washington had been arrested in this
cocaine sting how was the setup
conducted
well uh
7 27.
yeah marion barry had to be
brought up to the room
and he fought it for quite a while i
mean his the great lore was not drugs
but sex
uh rasheeda moore was marrying barry's
former lover they hadn't seen one
another for a while
she kept calling him up and actually
some of the reporting comes from people
who had been in his office in marion
barry's office that afternoon
she kept calling him up
to come to the room and he resisted it
because he had a sense too many nosy
rosies as he said literally
but uh she said look i just
got some take out food from downstairs
they're delivering it to my room why
don't you come up here and have a bite
to eat with me and and that became
uh the reason that marion barry actually
came to the room because he didn't want
to do that he kept saying i'll meet you
downstairs uh came to the room and uh
then uh it was a matter of rashida moore
actually
getting marry and barry to uh smoke uh
some crack and it took
a lot of convincing which i think was
one of the weakest part of the of the
federal government's case because if you
view the videotape it wasn't just
marion barry taking on a on a pipe it
was the the amount of time
and the amount of cajoling and the
amount of liquor
in the form of cognac that it took to
get marry and barry to light that crack
pipe in fact ken mundy the defense
attorney for barry who was um
who just played a remarkable role in in
in defending marion barry uh
initially was the gas you know here's
the video tape it's like abscam and all
those other cases where you see people
in that instance people stuffing money
in their pockets for congress
in this case you had the mayor of
washington and that very clear picture
smoking crack cocaine and but ken mundy
was able to take the jurors back and say
now look what happened look look at all
the what happened before
he reached up and took the pipe and it
was and
whether it was legal entrapment was not
necessarily the issue can mundy wanted
the jurors to think it was entrapment
and they did and it was some
justification it took too long for
marion barry to do the uh problem do the
hit i think there are two hits and
there's even to this day now there are
some people complaining that the police
not only set marion barry up
but that also they risked his life that
he could have died from the head of that
cocaine
in the end how many count indictments
i think it was 14 14. how many counts
was he found guilty on one
and that was a misdemeanor a drug
account involving a woman named doris
crenshaw who was a
finer player minor player and a civil
rights friend of marion barry's and i
think it was a political
deal struck by the jury
uh to basically acquit on a number of
counts
and it was a country on 12 i think the
acquittal was on on on the visit so
right and but
again and then the judge thomas pinvo
jackson the reagan i think reagan
appointee uh played a classic role in in
stirring the racial fears of the city uh
the maximum time barry could get on that
one misdemeanor cocaine possession
charge was six months and and the judge
made it clear he made a speech in which
he would disparage the jury's findings
and sentence barry to the six months so
even to this day there are many people
who think that mary and barry got a raw
deal in fact somebody would the harshest
thing i've heard one person say
is that uh ted kennedy had his problems
with chapter critic and someone died but
here he was running for the senate and
being considered as a national candidate
for president
long afterwards marion barry was
personally involved with drugs and even
that the judge treated him uh so harshly
in fact the judge could have put him on
pro day probation and he would not have
had to serve one day in jail reaction to
this book
well by and large it's it's been
terrific and gratifying for for me uh
because people read the book i mean
people uh
you know there are a lot of non-fiction
books about politics that are kind of
dry
and uh this book has enough going on
that people really enjoy it i think that
that the people who we quote
and the information that we present has
not been challenged in any serious way
by anybody
back to this uh
dedication in memory of my father joseph
joseph jackie
who taught me to love books and for my
mother zelda who believes in me and then
for tom sherwood for my son peyton
who once innocently illuminated all the
time spent on this project by telling a
caller
he's not here he's working on that damn
book it took a long time it took a long
time for four years
apart from our own fall abilities and
jobs we had to do we had to put up with
the publishing industry simon schuster
is a big organization and and all the
problems of putting anything together
probably the show too it was just took a
long time but we think we did the right
for the people of the country to
understand more about their nation's
capital we think it's
we wrote it of course but we think it's
the best book about the nation's capital
it tells you how the congress set up a
very bad system
and some of the local politicians here
made it worse
harry jaffe with washingtonian magazine
tom sherwood with local station wrc this
is the book dream city and we thank you
both for joining us thank you
[Music]
you